а щури поза dios broen їх сепаратистів
br відчинив з хіт україни на гарячу
точку геть і упирають проросійським їх
ослами язик живу боці барикаду
українські сили вигуки на мага і все
видно у цій контроль над регіоном
али поки безрезультатно
їжі на дія в українському конфлікті на
міжнародне посередництво
швейцарський дипломат ти
Гульдом він впав на важливу організацію з
bsp рік образить місце в Європі кошик
і пасерувати казус або саган сказав
пальма
ми з turbo vanette у чоловіка за повстане
з одиниць ситуація вішалася а під
вчаться nadia над ще зарості можна хоч
про стабілізатор нас є у мене
stabilizing
видно було нестабільності ж було
підступам кут його їм з ним очено
франк-вальтер штайнмайєр аяту їх
бундестагу за другу конференції в женеві
пдд все
формований проводами мною стива приводу
здалося що владний травень так їх то
витка дав би але вже ні сказав зустріч за
раз потрібно краще щоб перед доступною
за зустріч
шустрит трохи розчинення конкретної
дорожні карти планку не піднімалася що
дні вище та вище
що правда porsche женевська конференція
17 quit не дарма що я провалився a
safety in одумавшись prada ескалацію
бік конфлікту на tatra молися та догляд
у team на думку наук вівця вардингу
рихтера
краще альтернативи з 1 травня кілочки
полковник бундесверу з інтервали годину
противагу я обожнюю ця єдиним а житловим
шляхом дітей компромісу
даяков взув і за краще не всі сторони
як українці так і центри у пливу зубів
store daewoo matiz США та євросоюз запитай
у вас land самий у Росії чого ти ж не
випробувавши президент швейцарії ще
головою на нього все
единбург холдер петля поговоривши з ним
президент путін за іколів зібрати і
стиву середній україні перенести супер і
щоб референдум
можна посмажитись на нього все
нині в Україні просіяти понад 100
міжнародних постригу chill & bass head
але президентських виборів 25 травня
екстану ще більше
цивільний то легко vespa старого че
mike's брата інформацію просто нові
зараз правом чи ден і весь когось
політичну ситуацію майже які колись
вважали тому вперед запекла питання
стояння світ за ходом то окраїнам і
варшавського договору про боячись цю дисплея
лазала вірджинію конфлікту сварки воші
атмосферу інформацію про цю зарости
адже роль у вона граючи сьогодні ми не так
вже і dc протягнувши організація створі
навчитися і холодні видно для гармат у
діалогу
могла перешкод і важливу роль зараз-за
нових обставлений диктувати продається
правою на організації оскільки в ній все
dash а ви можете хвали ось і рішення
адже консенсусу таких нестінг а потім
ще на вигляд з пустирі женя в Україні
пов'язаний з ви камери заком і
на владному дозі вигляді пара каналів члени
верифікаційною місією брати
інспекторів біля будинку числі 4 німецьких
громадян
проросійські сепаратисти взяли в
заручником їх здалося цю гру мати
кістки як об'єкт застави як вона слідів
негайно поки що не на цілі тамади
україни владних ризикових постерів.
місячною прихованих ніколас і мовляв ними
чину хоче ті гнутий у конфлікт і стінки
тасс я обожнюю нашим солдатам там на
матчі вашу коти ми зараза зараз у форму
про 1914
через цахала повторити ваші роботи ми
не хочемо і стадії вода ризикових
все та так що це за будь-якого але ми
чомусь стасова ти з цивілізації б ви
поранені через неправдиву інформацію на риф
пропагандистську машину одні та аварійну
сторони ганзою так і як україна стоїть
на ми їх румунською держава стала
заручником для відстані між Росією
і це за ходом новий шлях
політичних суперечок пливу
али харчування ідентичності
ананд as in олекса ціна устілки розколотий
україну отрута україна
ми можна ти гнутою до одного краще їм
кроку полюсу сліди знати що з але
про заходить про російські тенденції як
що проводить політику на поляризацію тем
краще вже україну
водному на премію місяць розпадається на
дату намагаючись
поршневий означає і подалі за
зовнішньополітичний курс вкрай злитий за
клас ти край горілку неновини то
насильства обидва з я за пропана вала
бік конфлікту дорожню карту
деескалації
альтернатив поки не травня